on prend un petit morceau on le pose
délicatement sur tue pas criaient et
ensuite le
déguisement en bloc en tronche ou poêlée
le foie gras est un nom incontournable
des fêtes de fin d'année
mais à votre table de noël il sera
peut-être sujet de discorde carlo foie
gras n'a pas bonne presse il est bien
loin le temps où nos grands-mères gaver
à la main était comme ça qu'on avait
c'était en
720 but vide samir ça ça va un peu plus
vite mais pas assez
dans les années 70 la deux mondes de
foie gras augmente et une nouvelle
machine fait son apparition la glace est
un des leurs machines en fait
des machines électriques
on ne s'occupe de rien c'est le début du
foie gras industriels il se vend même en
conserve et devient un produit de
consommation de masse longtemps réservée
aux gourmets fortunés le foie gras est
de plus en plus à la portée des bourses
moyennes on peut se demander si une
véritable industrialisation de l'élevage
n'est pas en train de naître avec tout
ce que cela comporte de mauvais
mécanisation emploi d'aliments
artificielle ou de substances nocives
mais c'est surtout le gavage industriel
qui est critiquée dès 1977 le gavage tel
qu'il est fait actuellement rage sauvage
susciter la condesa base d'esprit
chagrin toujours soucieux de protéger
les animaux des esprits chagrins qui
vont de plus en plus se faire entendre
alors des éleveurs vont s'ouvrir les
portes de leur exploitation
l'objectif rassurer montré qu'ils
traitent bien leurs bêtes et qui n'ont
pas succombé aux dérives de
l'industrialisation comme cet éleveur
alsacien en 1991 je vous garantis que
l'animal souffre le moins possible je
veux pas dire qu'il ne souffre pas ça
joue franchement je ne peux pas le dire
mais ça se voit au niveau de son plumage
de sang de son état d'être que l'animal
souffre le moins possible
la souffrance animale c'est l'argument
phare en 2013 une vidéo de l214 dénonce
les dérives de cette industrie nous
sommes dans ce que l'on appelle une
salle de gavage ces images ont été
tournées clandestinement par une
association de défense des animaux des
canards morts ou blessés et pouvant à
peine bouger dans des cages minuscules
ses cages individuelles sont interdites
depuis 2016 mais le gavage industriel
lui est toujours une réalité en france
alors qu'au même moment la ville de new
york interdit la commercialisation du
foie gras à partir de 2022 veut
l'appétit la caf il a fait
[Musique]